this is a production of Cornell
University all right thank you so today
I'm gonna be talking about the role of
cucurbit asons in insight preference in
cheek our popipo
so for those you have heard me speak
before you know that or you may remember
that I have been working for the past
few years I'm trying to understand the
genetic and biochemical basis of striped
cucumber beetle preference and Cucurbita
pepo just like summer squash acorn
squash and zucchini and much this work
has been focused on resistance in leaf
tissue since that is a tissue that
matters the most to us here in New York
when we transplant squash into the
ground so it's been looking for
preference at that level and much this
work has started with looking at screen
injure plasm for a beetle damage and
other beetle centric bio assays to try
to understand the genetic basis of
preference and also identify traits that
are responsible for beetle preference
and do selection for nog referred
varieties unfortunately these beetles
are somewhat challenging to work with in
the sense that they have
seasonally dependent behaviors like
mating and aggregation which can really
confound some results and is
unfortunately not led to a lot of gain
in this regard so we're trying a few
other approaches so one of the
approaches i'm trying is working with a
proxy in sight for these beetles that
neither mates nor aggregates and I'm
using this as a proxy for selection for
these beetles as well as using them to
identify other chemical traits of plants
that impact insect preference and then
what another thing I'm doing which is
what to be the rest of my talk is about
today is looking at traits implants that
we hypothesize may be important for
insect preference mapping genetically
mapping them creating populations with
higher low of these compounds and then
seeing how the beetles respond to these
plants so that the last person we
talking about today and the compounding
question in the title my talk is cute
Kermit asons
so to start of an overview of what
contribute agents are tell you about
some mapping results we have and then of
course talk about what this means for
this striped cucumber beetle so key
carbocations are intensely bitter and
toxic try terpenoids
there's more than 20 types of cucurbit
Aysen in the Cucurbitaceae family and
everything we know about their
biosynthesis so far is from cucumber
another member of the family and the Pat
general pathway and cucumber is that
exceed o squalene an output of them a
lot Bev ilanic acid pathway is cyclized
in the cucurbit a die you know by the
bitter gene and then there's a number of
other steps of oxidation and to create
the final cucurbit a stone product and
in cucumber if plants had the functional
bittered allele there will be cube
basins in the cotyledons and only if the
plants have the bitter fruit or bitter
leaf transcription factors is the bitter
gene expressed in those tissues and
cucurbit asons that are in those tissues
and then for how big your raisins
relates to insects there's kind of two
main classifications of how organisms
deal if Q carpet Jason's so specialist
beetles light the stripe cucumber beetle
have come of all the future bets and
they actually see Quester these two
kermit eight cents for their own
defenses and so they love these hi
cucumbers taste them whereas avoid low
cucurbit Aysen
plants on the other hand other
herbivores like spider mites and us we
find high levels toxic and but are fine
with lower levels so i'm going to start
with talking about our mapping work in
cue carbonate pipo so to curb appeal has
four types of cucurbit asons dbi and e b
is the most abundant and we measure it
with HPLC its highest in the cotyledons
and low and leaves so I mentioned
earlier that much my previous work had
been in leaf tissue everything I want to
talk about for cucurbit a Sens is all
measuring and selecting in the
cotyledons because that's where the
compounds are the highest and I'm
thinking about what germ plasm to use
for this mapping it's important to know
that in Cucurbita pepo
there are two subspecies Pipo Pipo which
includes pumpkin and zucchini and people
chicks Dana which includes acorn squash
and summer squash well they look quite
similar they're indeed from separate
domestication events and quite
genetically distinct and we know from
previous work that beetles really prefer
Pipo Pipo and cucumber tasting
aliens are high in people people and the
reverse is true in Peter tixinha so in
knowing our two phenotypes are aligned
of population structure we need to make
inner sub specific crosses and evaluate
these phenotypes in those so that's what
we did is he made a by pencil population
between a high cotyledon cucurbit a some
parent from pipa people and a low high
Delina cucurbitacin parents from people
take Santa and the high parents has
again pubertus and B is the highest D
and then followed by de and I expression
of all of these are highly correlated so
if you're high and B you'll be high in
the rest of them and well it's hard to
see you he Kermit aces en IR appreciably
higher in the high parent than the low
parent so I looked at 200 f2 individuals
Regina type ton of GBS and phenotype
them for all four cucurbit asons
and then we did QTL mapping and we found
one pretty convincing peak on chromosome
5 because it's an f2 we don't have a ton
of recombination in the region so it's
about a five hundred kilobases window
that we have who are working so fine map
that further interestingly this is not
the bitter gene homolog that we know
from cucumber that's on chromosome 12
and if you zoom in there's nothing close
to significant so that's one line of
evidence that the difference that we see
between these two populations is not due
to the bitter gene I also develop PCR
primers in Sanger sequence this bitter
gene homolog and there are no
indications that protein the protein
product would be any different between
these two parents so it seems like
there's a single gene making is
different and it's not the bitter gene
that we know so much about from cucumber
I also in this f2 population looked at
the highest and lowest producing f2 s
with three prime RNA seek to see if
there any genes expressed in this region
or elsewhere that would be responsible
for this phenotype and our most
differentially expressed gene was indeed
in this region on chromosome five and it
was an exceeded reductase which you
remember from
pathway for cucurbit Jason's there's a
series of oxidation steps to make the
final product so it seems plausible and
it is highly expressed in both the hi
parents and the high F 2 s and not
expressed in the low parent and low F
choose so yeah so we think we found
possibly a single gene that controlled
speaker Jason content in Q karbala pipo
and then bring this back to what the
implicit the motivation for this what
the implications for striped cucumber
beetles are so I'll remind you again
that there's these two subspecies
pepomattic Sina if you recall that our
high cuddly incubation parent was from
to curb the pepo beetles love both
leaves and cotyledons from the species
so we expect that the high parents gonna
have a lot of leaf and cotyledon damage
and the reverse is true for text a know
what I haven't told you yet is that leaf
cue Kermit a scents are low in both
subspecies that mentioned they were low
they're low across the board and even if
we try to induce cucumber tastes and
defenses through or bibury by the
striped cucumber beetle or other forms
of herbivore II the plant doesn't ever
respond by producing more cucurbit a
sense so so to answer the question of
what selecting for coddling and cucurbit
asons means for striped cucumber beetles
from the FT population I told you about
I selected the extreme of twos and I
self them to make f2 derived f3 family
is about 15 from either extreme and I
measured damage in the field so starting
with cotyledons so you can see our high
parents gets a lot of I'm sorry much
sure why that's like that well it's
supposed to be 50 and onward so anyway
so our high parent gets a lot of cattle
eat and damage and our low parent
doesn't likely would expect because of
the subspecies difference and because of
a cute Kermit Jason difference and when
we select for cuddling Keuka mutations
we see the same pattern for
beetle damage in the high qk rotation F
threes and Loki turbinates and F trees
which is good that's what we would
expect based on the evolutionary history
of the beetle with this compound
and nice to see that this would work as
a selection strategy for defending
euchre cotyledons against beetles on the
other hands and leaf tissue so again
these are these two separate subspecies
so we expect the high parent from the
preferred subspecies to have a lot of
damage compared to a low parent and we
see that again and there's a few reasons
why we may believe that selecting for
cotyledon cucumber Tysons may affect
leaf damage so for instance beetles
could be attracted to the cotyledons and
then move up to the leaves and damage
the leaves from there or perhaps there's
other related terpenoid compounds from
the biosynthetic pathway that provide a
signal let attracts the beetles to these
plants however we don't see any
difference in leaf damage between these
two selections so we find that leaf
damage is independent of cotyledon
cucurbit asons
so what does control leaf damage
well we've measured I measured a lot of
things including the phloem stat SAP how
sticky it is and like the mandibles of
beetles leaf nutrition and neither those
are is appreciably different between the
subspecies um however from some of the
work with the insight proxy I was
telling you about we have some exciting
results about volatile deterrents in the
non preferred subspecies and are making
progress
hopefully in selecting with this proxy
insect so in summary we've mapped a
kookabura hastened biosynthesis low SIA
and Cucurbita pepo and showed that low
cotyledon cucurbit a syns reduces beetle
damage Inc yes in cotyledons
but leaf damage is independent of that
and if that I would like to thank my lab
and committee a lot of people in the
chemical ecology area and all my funding
thank you
I don't have any questions wise when
you're you think of mapping population
how do you fina tired it's just like you
got beaten by a beetle and you didn't
this is just damaged yeah so for this we
actually used to be phenotypes the
cotyledon for cucurbit tasting content
so we just cut off a cotyledon and
extract it from there and then took DNA
from the leaf tissue later but in
previous mapping work we have yeah just
looked at damage to leaves and then
sequence them later
yes different classes of insect
predators like the specialize there's
just general ones if you reduce that's a
great question so the question was if
you are selecting for lowered cucurbit
asons to protect against beetles that
can be a problem for other insects and
the answer is yes it very well could be
but kind of like you were alluding to
actually in New York the striped
cucumber beetle is by far our biggest
pest problem and it's so it's kind of
and we don't have a lot of other pests
that we see as important as important as
a strike cucumber beetle so may be worth
the trade-off in this region that these
volatile potentially are sort of
correlated in the parents so
carbocations goes with certain follicles
in the one parent and not the other
parent but then once you want to make
thematic population they're they're
uncorrelated in the population yeah so
yeah I probably didn't do a great job
explaining this so the key here but a
since they're pretty large compounds so
they are not volatile but other parts
like intermediate steps are small enough
that they could be volatile compounds
and our hypothesis for why high
cucurbitacin content in the leaves could
be due to some of those intermediate or
byproduct compounds but the volatile
result I was talking about has nothing
to do if you carbon taste it's we think
it's a set we don't know what it is but
it seems to be a separate compound yes
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu